sans revenus depuis huit mois ses
employés de restaurants de discothèques
sont en chômage partiel
ils n'ont jamais touché un centime des
prestations auxquelles ils ont pourtant
droit
je suis en chômage partiel depuis le
début de la pandémie depuis le 13 mars
et je n'ai pas touché un centime quand
j'appelle au service emploi il ne répond
pas c'est impossible de communiquer avec
eux qui envoient des mails et il ne te
répondent pas et ont laissé de prendre
rendez vous par internet on ne peut pas
c'est impossible
comment peuvent-ils convives ils disent
allez on ferme tout pour que les gens ne
se contaminent pas pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de morts ok mais nous on va mourir
de faim moi je suis jeune et grâce à
dieu je peux retourner vivre chez mes
parents
mais beaucoup de gens n'ont pas leur
famille ici plus de cent mille salariés
ont eu recours au chômage partiel lors
de la première vague épidémique près de
80000 depuis le début de la deuxième
l'inm l'équivalent de pôle emploi en
france n'auraient pas su gérer
l'avalanche de dossiers
le service emploi il faut tout faire en
ligne est comme ça sature me site
internet ne fonctionne plus c'est le
bazar
le site se bloque et moi je n'ai rien
touché depuis le mois de juin
regardez quel mois nous sommes annoncées
en grandes pompes par le gouvernement de
coalition socialiste podemos en juin
dernier le tout nouveau revenu minimum
vital n'est lui aussi jamais arrivé sur
les comptes bancaires des demandeurs
alors l'espagne on ne peut pas faire ça
et avec les gens on peut pas faire ça on
peut pas permettre ça ah non j'ai pas
que lui ces locaux de boire et pour nous
il habitait contre ça parce que ça c'est
incroyable ça arrive ça n'est ce pas ce
n'est pas c'est pas possible
de nombreuses aides financières ont été
annoncés pour pallier la crise sanitaire
les citoyens espagnols craignent de ne
jamais en voir la couleur